PROFESSOR: We have to set up
a little better the geometry
of the calculation.
And for that we have to
think of various angles.
We oriented there the electric
field along the z direction.
But that's not going to be too
convenient for our calculation.
So these calculations are
a bit of an art to do them.
They're not that trivial.
Not terribly difficult. But
I think if you appreciate it,
next time you ever have
to do one of these things
it will become clear.
So first your have
to think physically.
Is there an angle
in this problem?
Is there any important
angle happening here?
It's a question to you.
I think if you figure out that
you have a chance of doing
a diagram that reflects this.
Is there a physical angle,
you think, in this process?
A relevant angle?
Yes, Lou?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
Yeah.
The relevant angle is
you have a directional
ready for the electric field.
So if the electron
comes off there's
going to be an angle with
respect to that electric field.
So that's our physical
angle in this question.
So let's try to
draw this in a way.
So I will draw it this way.
And I brought colored
chalk for this.
I'll put the z-axis here, and
I'll put the electron momentum
in this direction.
k is the lateral momentum.
Now the electric
field is going to come
at some angle with
respect to the--
or the electron momentum is
at some angle with respect
to the electric field.
So that angle will
presumably stay there
for the rest of the calculation.
So let's do it with green.
So here is my electric field.
And it's going to have an
angle theta with respect
to the direction of the electric
field or the photon incident
direction.
Now, this is actually more like
the polarization of the photon.
The electric field is the
direction of the polarization
of the photon.
So one more vector, however,
the position that we
have to integrate over--
because we have the whole
hydrogen atom and the whole
of space to integrate.
So x has a position.
So I'll use another color here.
Unfortunately, the colors
are not that different.
Here is r, the vector r.
So now I have several angles.
I have theta for
the electric field.
But now that I've put all this
axis I not only have theta,
but I also have phi
for the electric field.
And for r, I will have
theta prime and phi prime.
So r has a theta
prime and a phi prime.
We usually have theta and phi.
But the answers, at
the end of the day,
are going to depend on theta.
And if you have theta here,
we want the theta to remain.
So theta prime and
phi prime are going
to be our variables
of integration
because you integrate over r.
Finally, we have one more
angle that we have to define.
So we have theta phi,
theta prime, phi prime,
and the angle that was here--
this was the angle between
r and the direction
of the electric field.
And we called it theta.
So we have to give
it a new name here.
And this angle, I'll
call it gamma here.
The angle between E and r.
OK.
So We have everything
defined here.
Maybe I should list it.
E has angles theta and
phi, the direction of E. r
has angles theta
prime and phi prime.
And gamma is the
angle between E and r.
And k along z hat.
So this is our situation.
So what are we
trying to calculate?
Well, we want to use
Fermi's golden rule.
So we need to calculate
final H prime initial.
That's the matrix element
of the Hamiltonian H
prime between the final
and initial states.
So what is this?
Well, these are
all wave functions
that depend all over space, and
this is a function of space.
So let's do it.
This is integral d cubed x.
Let's put the final state first
because it shows up there.
So it's 1 over L cubed e
to the minus i k dot r.
So here is our final
state, u final.
Then the Hamiltonian.
That's simple.
e E0 r cosine what?
Cosine gamma.
Is that right?
This is what we had there.
It's the angle between
the electric field and r.
It was theta to begin
but now has become gamma.
And then the final state.
So this is our H prime.
And then the initial state
is 1 over pi a0 cubed
e to the minus r over a0.
OK.
This is our task.
This is a matrix,
and here it is.
An integral of a plane wave
against an electron wave
function and an extra
r dependence here.
This could range from undoable
to difficult, basically.
And happily, it's just
a little difficult.
But this is an integral--
we'll see what are the
challenges on this integral.
So let's take a
few constants out.
So e, E0, pi, a0,
that all will go out.
So this is e E0 over square
root of pi l cubed a0 cubed.
So I took the l's out,
the e, E, this thing.
All right.
Let's write the integral
more explicitly.
This is r squared dr
sine the volume element.
Sine theta d theta d phi.
But I'm integrating over x,
which is integrating over r.
And r is theta
prime and phi prime.
So these are all these ones.
I'm integrating over all values
of theta prime and phi prime.
Then what do I have?
I have this exponent, k dot r.
Well, my diagram shows
how k dot r is easy.
It involves a cosine
of theta prime.
So it's e to the minus
ik, the magnitude of k,
the magnitude of r
cosine theta prime,
because after all, k
was along the z-axis.
r is along the phi
theta prime direction.
OK.
We're progressing.
This, this, that term,
it's r cosine gamma.
And the final term is not that
difficult. e to the minus r
over a0.
That's what we have to do.
An integral over phi
prime, theta prime, and r.
This is our challenge.
And the reason it's a
challenge is the cosine gamma
because this gamma is the angle.
It depends on theta, depends
on theta prime, depends on phi,
phi prime.
That's the problem.
If we can solve that
cosine gamma thing
we can do this integral.
And I think even if you
were doing it numerically,
that cosine gamma there is
a little bit of a headache.
You don't want to do an
integral that you can really
do like this numerically.
So you really want to do it.
So what we need is to calculate.
So we can begin by
saying, I'm going
to calculate what
cosine gamma is.
And here is the way you
can calculate cosine gamma.
When you have two
unit vectors, cosine
of the angle between
two unit vectors
is just the dot product
of those two unit vectors.
So for gamma, we can consider
a unit vector along e
and a unit vector along r
and take the dot product.
And remember, for an
arbitrary unit vector,
it's sine theta cos phi sine
theta sine phi cos theta.
This is the theta
phi decomposition
of an arbitrary unit vector.
So cosine gamma
is the dot product
of a vector n along the e
times a vector n along r.
And vector n along
e and r are just
with theta in one case and phi
and theta prime and phi prime.
So when I make
the dot product, I
get sine theta, cos phi, sine
theta prime, cos phi prime.
That is the product
of the x components.
Plus sine theta, sine phi prime
times sine theta and sine phi.
Sine theta prime sine phi
prime, plus cos theta,
cos theta prime.
OK.
Doesn't look much easier,
but at least it's explicit.
But it's actually much easier.
And why is that?
Because there's a lot of
factors in common here.
In fact, sine theta and sine
theta prime are in both.
So what you get
here is cosine gamma
is equal to sine theta
sine theta prime.
And then you have
cos phi, cos phi
prime, plus sine
phi, sine phi prime.
And that's cosine of phi minus
phi prime plus cos theta cos
theta prime.
OK.
So that's cosine gamma.
Now suppose you were to put
this whole thing in here.
It's a big mess but all
quantities that we know.
But there's one
nice thing, though--
a very nice thing happening.
Think of the interval
over d phi prime.
This does not
depend on phi prime.
But cosine gamma can
But here it has this thing,
cosine of phi minus phi prime.
So when you try to do the
integral of this phi prime
with this term,
this term will give,
eventually, the integral
of d phi prime times
cosine of phi minus phi prime.
There is a lot of messy things.
But this integral
is 0 because you
are averaging over a full term.
So happily, all this
term will not contribute.
And that's what makes
the integral doable.
So what do we have then?
Our whole matrix
element, f H prime i,
has become e E0 over square
root of pi l cube a0 cube.
And now you just
have to integrate.
This is the only term
that contributes.
And when you put
this term, for sure
you can now do the
d phi prime integral
because that term
is phi dependent.
So that integral gives
you just a factor
of 2 pi from the
integral of d phi.
And from this
thing, cosine theta
is the angle between the
electric field and k.
So it's a constant
for your integral.
You're integrating over
theta prime and phi prime.
So cosine theta also goes out.
And here is the
integral that remains.
r cube dr. It was r squared,
but there was an extra r
from the perturbation.
r cubed dr into the
minus a over r--
r over a0.
And this thing you can
pass two cosine variables.
It's pretty useful.
So this goes minus
1 to 1 d cos theta
prime, cos theta prime e to
the minus ikr cos theta prime.
This cos theta prime
came from here.
And that's it.
So this is a nice result.
It looks still difficult,
but we've made great progress.
And in fact, we've dealt
with a really difficult part
of this problem, which
is orienting yourself
of how you're going to
approach the matrix element.
So to finish up I'll just
give you a little more
of the answer.
We'll complete the discussion.
We need probably 15 more
minutes to finish it up.
So the only thing
I'm going to say now
is that if you
look at the notes,
every integral here
is easily doable.
So basically, there's
two integrals.
And the way to do them is
first do the r integral.
You will have to
have these terms.
And then do the theta integral.
And they are kind of
simple, both of them.
You have to keep up
a lot of constants.
But here is the answer
for the matrix element.
So that part of the integral
I think you all can do.
But you have to take your time.
i 32 square root of pi e E0 a0.
I did a lot of work
here, actually,
in writing it in a
comprehensible way
because it's pretty messy.
l cube a0 cube, 1
over 1 plus k squared
a0 squared cube cosine theta.
By now, it starts to
simplify a little.
OK.
That was actually plenty of work
to get it to write it this way.
I feel pretty happy
about that writing.
Why?
First, OK, there
is these numbers.
Nothing I can do about it.
But there's a
multitude of constants
that I have simplified and
done all kinds of things.
But it was not worth it.
First, ka0, that is unit free.
This is unit free.
k is 1 over length.
ka0 to the 4 is the length cube,
and here is the length cube.
No units here either.
Here, nice units.
This is units of energy.
Why?
Electric field times
distance is potential,
times electric charge is energy.
Energy.
So this is how this should be.
The matrix element of an energy
between normalizable states
should be an energy.
And that has become clear here.
The next steps that we have to
do, which we'll do next time,
is to integrate over states, and
put in the density of states,
and do a little simplification.
But now it's all trivial.
We don't really have
to integrate anymore
because Fermi's golden
rule did the job for us.